das war das grünen Mantra gegen die
Angst der Deutschen vor dem teuerstrom
im krisenwinter ein Weiterbetrieb von
Kernkraftwerken der Mache Strom gar
nicht billiger und er helfe auch gar
nicht gegen die Russen Gaskrise tja das
war ein riesen Lügenmärchen ja das zeigt
nur in eine Recherche der Welt am
Sonntag dafür wurden 166 Dokumente aus
Umwelt und Wirtschaftsministerium
ausgewertet und aus den Unterlagen
geht's klar hervor die grünenminister
die hatten ja AKW nein schon im März
vorformuliert also noch lange vor
prüfende
der Weiterbetrieb der AKW hat keine
Auswirkungen auf den Strompreis
Deutschland hat kein Stromproblem durch
AKW lässt sich fast kein CO2 einsparen
diese Lügen haben uns die Grünen rund um
Robert Habeck aufgetischt um mit dem
co2-märchen direkt mal aufzuräumen
tatsächlich während es pro Jahr 25 bis
30 Millionen Tonnen CO2 weniger im
deutschen Strommarkt übrigens die
Ministerien für Wirtschaft und Umwelt
hatten die Ablehnung einer
Laufzeitverlängerung weitgehend
vorformuliert und das noch bevor eine
intensive Prüfung des Sachverhalts
stattgefunden hatte das Nein zu längeren
AKW-Laufzeiten stand offenbar sogar im
Widerspruch zu Einschätzungen von
Fachbeamten des Wirtschaftsministeriums
selbst für die weitere Atomdiskussion in
der Energiekrise verheißt das nichts
Gutes es zeigt sich nämlich Ideologie
geht bei den Grünen vor Fakten die
fachebenen der eigenen Ministerien waren
zu dem Schluss gekommen der Strompreis
könne sinken und die Netzstabilität
Werte erhöht wenn die AKW weiterlaufen
all das wurde von den Grünen unter den
Teppich gekehrt um den deutschen ihr
ganz eigenes AKW Märchen zu erzählen die
Grünen wollten ihren Skype den
Atomausstieg und das auf Kosten der
Wahrheit
[Musik]
er verschweigende scheint das ganz große
Thema in der Politik an diesem Montag zu
sein sprechen wir darüber jetzt mit
unserem bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer hier
bei uns im Studio schön dass du hier
bist was ist los bei den Grünen was kann
man ihnen überhaupt noch glauben fragt
man sich also so etwas was wir auch
gerade im Beitrag gesehen haben und was
die Welt am Sonntag Kollegen da
herausgefunden haben das wiegt natürlich
wirklich schwer man kann fast den Anouk
haben der Minister für Klimaschutz ist
fast ein Minister für Klimaschutz also
Robert Habeck verschweigt essentielle
Dinge die seine Beamten ihm und auch die
Beamten von Umweltministerin Steffi
Lemke aufgeschrieben haben
beispielsweise das Faktum dass der
Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke den
CO2-Ausstoß ab 2024 noch mal deutlich
senken würde um 25 bis 30 Millionen
Tonnen wir müssen einmal gegen schneiden
ein Tempolimit für das die Grünen
vehement eintreten das würde ungefähr 5
Millionen Tonnen CO2 Einsparung pro Jahr
bringen also ein Fünftel dessen was man
mit ein bisschen Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke bekommen könnt und
deswegen ist umso brisanter eigentlich
das Robert Habeck das eine verschweigt
das andere aber unbedingt will und dann
sind wir wieder bei der Frage was kann
man da noch glauben da muss ich als
Bürger ehrlicherweise sagen da kann ich
nicht mehr viel glauben weil wirklich
wirklich deutlich wird hier geht
Ideologie vor ganz normalen nüchternen
Argumenten das ging ja sogar so weit
dass er dann gesagt hat also bevor ich
irgendwas mit Atomkraftwerken zu tun
haben will da baue ich lieber oft
schmutzige offshore Kohlekraftwerke
irgendwie aus dritter Dritter Welt
Manier wieso machen die Grünen das die
müssen doch auch verstehen dass gerade
in dieser Politikverdrossenheit die
sowieso schon herrscht dass sie damit
das Vertrauen der Bürger komplett
verspielen und sie schlechtesten Fall
eben auch nach links und rechts extrem
verlieren jede Partei an Markenkern und
der grüne Markenkern ist entstanden um
das Thema anti-akkw also der Kampf gegen
die Kernkraft der ist das Herz die
Herzkammer muss Ansagen der Grünen das
ist wirklich
das was die Partei am Ende hat groß
werden lassen und was die Partei auch im
Innersten dann zusammenhält und an den
Kern wagt sich natürlich auch Robert
Habeck nicht ran er sieht aber natürlich
jetzt in der Regierung da gibt es eine
Realitätscheck dass diese ganze
anti-akkw-bewegung der Grünen auf
falschem Sand gebaut ist oder muss sagen
auf Sand gebaut ist sie erodiert wenn
wir über die Frage reden wie kriegen wir
CO2 aus der Luft oder wie bekommen wir
weniger CO2 Luft dann ist Kernkraft
total wichtig und dann sind wir genau
bei der Frage
Glaubwürdigkeit Glaubwürdigkeit was
bleibt da übrig fördert das die
Politikverdrossenheit ich würde sagen
auf jeden Fall sie tut es vor allem ich
weiß auch nicht wie es Euch beiden geht
aber ich dachte immer die Grünen sind
eigentlich eine Umweltschutz und
klimaschutzpartei und nicht nur eine
anti-atomkraftpartei aber offensichtlich
sind sie nur noch das es gibt viele
Gründe die für Kernkraft sprechen es
gibt auch Gründe die dagegen sprechen
die muss man nach ernst nehmen die Frage
Endlager ist so eine aber wir müssen uns
auch in Deutschland vergegenwärtigen
warum eigentlich das industriel Nummer
vier dieser Welt anders als die anderen
drei Industrieländer die vor uns liegen
nämlich die USA China und Japan und auch
viele Länder die nicht ganz so stark
sind aber auch viel Industrie haben wie
beispielsweise Frankreich oder
Großbritannien oder auch die
Tschechische Republik auf den
Weiterbetrieb von kernkraftätzen sogar
auf den Neubau von Kernkraftwerken
selbst Japan setzt ja darauf warum tun
die das und warum sind wir eigentlich
der Meinung dass unser Weg im Vergleich
der anderen der einzig richtige ist aus
der Kernkraft auszusteigen also das
müssen wir wirklich diskutieren ein
Wirtschaftsminister dieses viertgrößten
und führt wichtigsten Landes der Welt
was die industriestärke und die
Wirtschaftsstärke angeht der muss sich
diese Frage stellen der darf nicht
Ideologie getrieben handeln sondern der
muss an Arbeitsplätze denken der muss an
Firmen denken und der muss wenn er an
den Klimaschutz denkt auch an CO2 denken
und da fällt einfach die Bilanz für
Kernkraft deutlich deutlich besser aus
als für Kohle und für Gas und als die
Grünen ist darstellen was bedeutet diese
Blockadehaltung der grün für die
Handlungsfähigkeit der gesamten
Regierung man fragt sich in dem
Zusammenhang auch was ist eigentlich mit
der FDP ja bei der FDP das hören wir
grummelt ist und rumort ist wirklich
hinter den Kulissen sehr sehr hörbar
Robert Habeck hat ja mit seinem
monatelangen nein gegen den
Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke zu
einem innerkoalitionären Streit geführt
hat auch dazu geführt dass Olaf Scholz
ja erstmal seit Jahrzehnten ein
Machtwort sprechen musste von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz Gebrauch machen
musste und das was wir hören ist dass
die FDP natürlich höchst erbost darüber
ist dass Robert Habeck hier ganz ganz
wichtige Hinweise seine eigenen Beamten
einfach
ignoriert hat klar ist das Thema
Kernkraft ist seit dem Wochenende wieder
voll auf der Agenda der Ampel Koalition
das was Olaf Scholz mit seinem Machtwort
mit seiner Richtlinienkompetenz
eigentlich unterbinden wollte das hat
genau zwei Wochen gehalten das Thema ist
wieder da und es liegt daran dass Robert
Habeck hier massiv getäuscht und
geschummelt hat wir dürfen gespannt sein
wie dieser Streit jetzt noch weitergeht
Dankeschön Jan für deine Eltern
[Musik]